we estimate that somewhere between 200
and 250 metric tons of cocaine are
shipped out of Venezuela by these routes
a virtual news conference but for a very
real target today I'm here to talk about
the former Maduro regime and its direct
participation in narco-terrorism
corruption money laundering and drug
trafficking the series of charges
against Nicolas Maduro the man who leads
Venezuela and some of them were senior
figures in his government the Justice
Department alleges that running a drug
gang called the cartel of the sons would
do two what with the FARC rebels in
Colombia to ship hundreds of tons of
cocaine into the u.s. taking bribes and
sharing the profits Maduro and his other
defendants have betrayed the Venezuelan
people and corrupted Venezuela's
institutions while the Venezuelan people
suffer this cabal lines their pockets
with drug money and the proceeds of
their corruption and this has to come to
an end
the charges will be seen as a
significant escalation and the Trump
administration's efforts to remove
Nicolas Maduro from power it recognises
opposition leader one Guido as
Venezuela's president but despite
support from Washington and many of
Venezuela's neighbors Maduro remains in
the presidential palace he's overseen
the economic collapse of one of the
world's biggest oil producers with
millions leaving the country but on
Twitter he remained defiant claiming the
US and its ally Colombia wanted to fill
Venezuela with violence and vowing he
would not be defeated
in 1989 the u.s. took military action to
remove Manuel Noriega from Panama
accusing him of running a massive drug
operation at this stage is unlikely
Maduro will see the inside of the US
courtroom he faces life in prison if
ever convicted with the u.s. offering a
50 million dollar reward hoping that
might convince someone to send him its
way Alan Fisher al Jazeera Washington